miss attack that took place in two
fairly small city of Christchurch New
Zealand was one with massive
ramification this is part of an
increasingly global phenomenon of white
nationalist white supremacist violence
my name is Connie Tarrou I am an author
and a broadcaster and I write quite a
bit about multiculturalism and
globalization the attacker in
Christchurch inscribed on his gun the
name of an Italian militant who shot six
African men in Italy in 2017 he also
inscribed the name of a québécois man
who went into a mosque in 2017 and
killed six worshippers there he was
consciously enacting his part in what he
sees as a global struggle the
Christchurch killer simply described
Muslims immigrants as invaders so we get
this immediate language of invasion of
opposition of clash and war you see
echoes of that in the way the man who
committed the attack on the tree of life
synagogue in Pittsburgh would refer to
immigrants as invaders
he was particularly angry with the hias
activists in the synagogue because they
were helping settle refugees if you look
at attacks on places of worship just in
the United States in the last seven
years you've had what a white white
nationalist attack on a Sikh Gurdwara
and Wisconsin on predominantly black
church in Charleston on a synagogue in
Pennsylvania this is an ideology and a
tendency in American life in American
society that goes beyond just hatred of
Muslims these white nationalist ideas
are available freely on in in the sort
of far-right and right-wing media
landscape ideas like the white genocide
or the great replacement Theory come out
of the mouths of mainstream politicians
people like Steve King the the
congressman in Iowa who said famously
that we cannot restore our civilization
with other peoples they
a chilling statement for any American
politician to make in in terms of what
it suggests about the way he understands
culture and citizenship and belonging
but likewise you have a Fox News anchor
like Laura Ingraham saying that the
America we know and love no longer
exists the America that we know and love
doesn't exist anymore massive
demographic changes have been foisted
upon the American people and their
changes that none of us have were voted
for and most of us don't like now look
at that language massive demographic
changes have been foisted upon the
American people not only is that untrue
but what it's suggesting to its audience
very deliberately is that this what
would they imagine as great demographic
change is being done to them and this
borrows completely from the way white
nationalists also frame the issue of
immigration and the issue of demographic
change in their societies it's not
surprising that somebody like David Duke
the former head of the KKK was quick to
congratulate Laura Ingraham and say that
what he had heard her say on the TV was
most important and truthful monologue
he'd heard in American media
[Music]
the President of the United States
happily uses the same rhetoric just a
matter of hours after the Christchurch
attack he was sitting in the Oval Office
happily decrying what he called the
invasion of his country by Americans
people hate the word invasion but that's
what it is it's an invasion of drugs and
criminals in in some cases you have
killers coming in and murderers coming
in and we're not going to allow that to
happen it's going to see that language
also come out of the most powerful
office in the world I think a lot of
white nationalist terrorists see in
Trump a figure who vindicates for them
their rise on the world stage
until we as people who live in
ostensibly liberal societies can stress
that it's important to find solidarity
in our differences bigotry of this kind
is only going to get stronger